don't call it a violent white
supremacist insurrection but last night
in portland oregon a group of angry
white people attacked a federal
courthouse and set it on fire of course
they were
from antifa so it doesn't count by the
way there are still people inside the
building when they set it on fire
[Music]
so how did this start as if they need a
reason to break things and set buildings
on fire but in this case it was
portland's mayor the profoundly beta ted
wheeler
announcing that he's seeking two million
dollars for police funding
radio host jason rantz oversees the
pacific northwest and the lunacy there
for us
he joins us now jason thanks for coming
on um so
we just put a little more meat on these
boats why were they so mad
so in part because of what you just said
that
the mayor of uh portland has decided to
put more funding or try to get more
funding to the police department that
they defunded they got rid of the gun
reduction
violence gun violence reduction team and
since then there's been a rash of deadly
shootings they're on
pace to have another historic year but
on top of that on monday night
they actually the federal government
took down the boards and the fencing
around the federal courthouse which
meant
antifa now had a reason to go ahead and
attack it again so
they quickly tried to put up those
boards before the antifa violence
the antifa members showed up took them
all down burned them and
caused the traditional amount of chaos
that they do
and of course in portland like so many
other cities where this happens the
media there for the most part are
calling riots demonstrations
and they're calling domestic terrorists
simply protesters
so did hundreds of federal agents swoop
in grab everybody's cell phone throw
hundreds into
prison shoot unarmed people in portland
as they tried to burn a courthouse
no there was one arrest which actually
tells you it's rather instructive of a
number that based on what happened last
night only one person gets arrested it's
because in portland like in seattle and
other places police officers aren't able
to do their jobs
amazing jason rantz thank you for that